enzo you're back what made you want to
return
let's come out of retirement right now
it's been 10 years man
just sitting back seeing other people
get second
third chances that puts a little salty
taste in my mouth man
like the you know the chip on my
shoulders a little bit bigger so i i
want to play against the best man
i want to play against the best i want
to solidify my legacy man
i don't want i don't want it to be like
lightning in the bottle like i did it
one year i got to the end
i want to win this
it has been 10 years how have you
changed since then
and how different will your game play be
i've changed a lot man
since these 10 years i had another kid
so i got a son and a daughter now
i went through a messy divorce i went
through that
and then on top of that i lost my father
my best friend
so i've i've changed as a human i've
changed man you know so
and i'm single i'm gonna play this game
single now so i don't know if that
if that's gonna i don't know man i don't
want to mess my gamer but i am taking
some applications
not in the beginning so it's like the
middle towards the end
sounds like you might be treating this
as an opportunity to
make a love connection i don't want to
do that i don't want to do it because i
know this game
i'm not here for that but if it gets
like the end
we'll see you know maybe i'll get a
little action you know what i mean so
you're open to a show man so it sounds
like very open
i'm open to showmance but not in the
beginning i don't want it in the
beginning
i don't want it in the middle if i get
to if i last to the end maybe towards
the end definitely
because at that point it don't matter
you're gonna get put on the block anyway
don't matter
wow okay well um what are you looking
for in a potential showmance
a female a good looking female
if it happens it happens i'm not looking
for it might not be looking for it but
being single being a good looking guy
will you use that to your advantage and
maybe flirting a little bit making some
connections and playing this game
oh definitely i'm definitely going to
get much there's no question about it
the meow meow will definitely get his
flared arms definitely
what do you consider to be your biggest
strengths going in here
i just think my socially i'm very
likable you know what i mean i know how
to
just make you like me you know what i
mean i that's i'm gonna use that
in the beginning just keep i'm nice and
calm and cool like i always do it
i'm not going to ruffle any feathers
early i don't over
play i see a lot of people get in this
house and over play too fast i don't do
that
i sit back i i scan the whole house i
see who's in this house
and then i start making my relationships
with everybody well we know you're
behind one of the most successful
alliances in big brother history will we
see
round two of another unforgettable
alliance
well the worst has finally happened to
us we got two brigade members up on the
block
i hate to say it you know um it might be
time for maddie to get whacked here you
know
he might have we might have to size him
up for some cement shoes check out my
brigade shirts
i got my brigade hats i got my sweaters
so i
i mean i hope there's somebody from the
brigade just for just some protection or
whatever but
i mean i'm definitely gonna represent my
squad well when you found out it was all
stars you had to wonder who's gonna be
in there
uh who would you be excited to see and
who would you be nervous to see
well i would like to see hayden hayden
morris from icy just because
he wins they'll protect me uh you know
there's a loyalty there so i would like
to see that i don't want to see anyone
else for my season but probably him
i think my season was just too easy i
don't want no one for my city i want i
want this to be a challenge i actually
want an enemy this time i want an enemy
someone to keep me on my feet so i'm
going to keep me sharp i want that so
i don't really care who they bring i
want the best of the best i just want
the best of the best let's go at it
let's see what happens
well looking back what was your fatal
mistake last time if your season was too
easy why didn't you win
hayden was smart i lost the competition
at the end
i think if i were the only thing i would
think now
to do differently if i had to if i get
to the end is to bring people in the
final three where i think i could be
doing competitions i couldn't beat
hayden and i couldn't be lane at the end
they were just better than me that's it
and my hat's awesome they were better
than me and he was smart not to take me
he was very smart
what have you been doing to prepare i
watch season's hair and there i do
just thinking of people who would be in
this house so
i watch that person season or this
person's season see how they talk
see how they you know just tells on when
they lie what they do when they like
just any little thing just anything any
bit of information
i've been working out i'm 42 years old
look at me i look great for 42 i know
that you know just
i'm ready man i'm i'm so ready for this
challenge
i'm predicting it right now i think
you're hooking up with somebody in there
oh
i know that definitely definitely i know
but not early not early please not earn
well why not early because
you don't want it to be just a hookup
you want it to be something real
i just feel like it's going to mess my
game up it's going to okay it's all
about the game
i'm going to cloud my judgment a little
bit i don't want that what do you think
the game will be like
for people coming off of quarantine and
a global pandemic what will it be like
for you in there you know you've got
your kids on the outside
i think i think it's gonna be like this
season is gonna be like one for the ages
it's just
the world that you live in right now
like you said with the whole covet
i i think there's no like real live tv
right now i think the pressure is gonna
be at an all-time high for a lot of
people here
there's gonna be a lot of a lot of tears
a lot of people cry it's gonna be crazy
and i cannot wait to take part
if you could label what your role in
this
you what you know what show is what's
your role
my role in the show um
i'm i feel like i am one of the greats
now i have to solidify that
i did it on season 12 making one of the
best alliances of all time
now i got to do this for me i got to
make myself one of the greats
we talked about the pandemic and this is
a crazy time for the world it's also
it's an election year people are
on edge whenever politics comes up what
do you think happens if that gets
discussed in the house
i'm walking away i don't care i don't
care who's democrat or republican i just
i walk i walk away i just
i feel like no one wins in that debate i
feel like there's just
you know everyone's just gonna argue and
that's it i just i don't care too much
about policy
uh so who's gonna be on your mind as
you're trying to win this thing
oh my god my kids my my beautiful son my
beautiful daughter
my brother a little whack a little whack
i'm doing this for him
and then my father man i feel like he
pulled some strings up there
to get me in this position right now so
he's on my heart heavy
heavy on my heart so i'm gonna play this
game for him definitely
what do you think the odds are that you
that come out of this with a real
relationship a real love story
i'm gonna hook up i know that i know me
i'm definitely hooking up with somebody
i know that eventually
will it be two people i hook up with i
don't know will it be real or will it
just be for the game
look you got to make me laugh you got to
bug with me you got to make me laugh
i mean i'm like i always say i'm the
youngest oldest dude you'll ever meet
you know i mean i'm a kid at heart so
we'll see you know what i mean you got
to make me laugh that's one thing and
then
and then if there's loyalty there and
there's trust and i feel like it's real
then we'll see you know i won't like
shun
a relationship because of what happened
with my match i won't do that you know
what i mean i give everyone everyone's
got a shot
well you knew this was all stars so i
gotta ask were there women you were
hoping you'd see
in here um
as far as game wise yes game watch is
not hooking up wise
but then i was like i started going
through some seasons
i don't know i got a couple people in my
mind i just i don't know give me a name
who is it oh you know who made me laugh
the other day that girl cat
so then i was thinking what if miami
hooks up with cats she made me laugh a
lot on that scene so she was
she was hot too you know what i mean so
i thought it out just because of the cat
name that's that that was it
okay kitty cat and meow meow here we go
meow meow's a clean cat you know he
doesn't want to get dirty
how did you feel about all the protocols
you guys had to go through the testing
being in a bubble right now
ahead of going in we've been hanging out
watching movies you know
cooking just chilling relaxing sun pain
and working out in the back
i like we're getting tested too which is
good so i'm with it man
it's like a little vacation right now
before i go in there i mean i think we
all keep saying you know if any show
could pull off filming in a pandemic
it's big brother because you're already
quarantined in a house so
did that kind of cross your mind and how
do you feel like the pandemic might
affect the game overall
yeah i feel like if everyone gets tested
everyone comes back negative with it
that's it let's go game on let's get in
here and let's play this thing
it's not i i feel like new jersey we
we're like
we kind of like beat it it's leaving us
now so i'm i'm in that like
state of mind like all right it's past
us let's play this game man